richard sherman the 49ers their
cornerback joining us on the program
good morning how are you good morning
I'm doing okay we've been on this topic
here about favorite cars that have been
in movies and TVs and then I had I asked
Michael Vick his first car do you
remember your first car yeah what was it
it was a Ford Ford Taurus Taurus yeah 88
was it tricked out how did that work out
with the ladies I was noticing and I
forgot about this that you did you go to
Stanford as a white out and then changed
a corner okay
I'm curious would you still be in the
NFL if you're a wide receiver really
mm-hmm
do you wish you would have stayed at
wide receiver anytime you ever thought
about man
it's so easy now to be able to catch
passes it worked out pretty well for me
but I'm waiting for a rule to help the
defensive players if you were going to
talk to the commissioner and said hey
can we have this what would this be it
honestly they would never do that but I
just want less rules for that helped off
and honestly that would help us
tremendously like if you didn't have
five rules that could affect a defensive
player and give an automatic first down
on plays of 3rd and 80 it could be 3rd
and 80 and you get a run I mean a
receiver runs into a DB and they call
illegal contact automatic first then the
drive continues so I honestly I would
say just take away you know or just make
five-year are penalties 5 you are
penalties instead of automatic first
down
if I was a defensive back I would
probably hold on every play because I
don't and I I don't know if this was
your philosophy in Seattle but it felt
like you guys were gonna be physical and
probably said they're not going to call
everything what is your is your
philosophy any different than it was
you played in Seattle my my philosophy
would never hold every play and invites
the best abilities it is it you know
they can call the plank on every play
for anything you know they could say and
you touch the receiver past five yards
so you can call a legal contact on every
play if the receiver in the corner touch
so I mean you just can't worry about
those things when you plant you know you
just got a play as fast as you can the
cards can let the chips fall we spent a
lot of time on yesterday's show talking
about the NCAA and LeBron leading the
charge with the Governor of California
gavin newsom that let's let's change
this they pay for play your thoughts on
what what is the rule that should be in
place with us are you fine with what
they're proposing well I'm fine with
what they're proposing with with some
you know more to it because honestly I
get frustrated and one of my teammates
brought this up the other day you know
what's that what's the annual cost of
college tuition you you should say I
don't know it's depending on if it's
state school or private university is
probably 20 grand or so you know forty
four the super expensive ones
I think Stanford might be at the top at
like 60 so what's what what's the salary
for minimum wage worker in the u.s.
right now I think in Washington minimum
wage is 15 but you know it's probably
around 45 grand or so give or take yeah
so the amount of hours these kids work
every day it probably exceeds 40 hours
most of the time but if you just paid
them a salary for the hours that they
work they make more than their
scholarships every year just off the
strength if you just paid them pay them
a salary based not not anything crazy
not you know 80 hours eighty dollars an
hour if you pay them 20 bucks an hour
they would literally make more money
just with the same amount of hours that
they're working nothing changed then
their scholarship is work some of these
state schools I mean the scholarships
only worth 14 to 10 $14,000 so you're
saying these guys are working all these
hours all year long and their
scholarships ten thousand annually so
that forty thousand over four years so
you're saying forty thousand
for whatever amount of hours these guys
put in that's pretty ridiculous and and
that's what I get frustrated about I get
frustrated about the conversation about
amateurism when you you know they make a
huge case that these kids are amateurs
but these coaches are professionals and
that's always odd to me so how can you
you have professional coaches and
amateur kids you know some of these
coaches are making more than they did
NFL coaches yeah because they don't have
to pay the players so they have to pay
somebody they pay the coaches and you
got assistant coaches or getting you
know more than assistant coaches in the
NFL but how would you have marketed
yourself and your likeness at Stanford
to get paid I mean it just depends on
what opportunities I honestly don't know
I mean there's there's a ton there's not
a ton of like people aren't aren't as
crazy about football Sanford I mean no
Football capital but I think with some
kids it'll change their decision-making
in general like it will change how they
they even approach looking at schools
because if you can go to a school like
USC or Ohio State or Michigan where you
know the town is crazy about football
and get a scholarship and really you
know be able to be marketed by these
businesses and these in these used car
salesmen or our lives or whatever the
case may be then I think that'll make it
more attractive for some of these kids
to select those universities over the
universities they would not really
select and it honestly make more parity
because instead of you know five five
stars going to the same school they
honestly go to a different schools
because they'd be more marketable and
make more money if they went somewhere
else would you have gone to a different
school under these guidelines no no I
wouldn't win Stanford you know the
decision to go to Stanford wasn't about
any of that it was about the long-term
effects and the value of the degree and
I'm also wondering about this Richard
like let's say use eye on Williamson
went to Duke and even though they're
nice cool he says I'll go there but I
want my own shoe but it's gonna be a
Nike shoe but I want you to pay me a
million dollars I'm gonna be on national
TV 35 times
35 games can you see something like that
happen I know they're not many Zion
williamson's but it feels like every
once in a while we get one of those
players who's transcendent right I mean
you do but I think a lot of those
players are especially in terms of
basketball where a lot of the that shoe
money is are are doing their best to
avoid going to college in general you
know I mean I on did but some of them
are just going overseas and taking their
talent to Australia or the European
circuit and playing there because they
don't want to waste your time in college
and wasting energy and Ian c-double-a
any money and I respect that but I could
definitely see you know if another
transcended talent like Diane Williamson
came through the college ranks him
getting a crazy deal to come to one of
those schools and and that'd be good for
him they'd be good for him that'd be
good for for everybody because with
Wright as it stands right now we'll just
get that money you know if yeah if they
just get transcended talent and whatever
endorsement deals jersey sales etc etc
that he would have gotten you know just
from putting his face on the cover of a
magazine or the cover of a cup or bottle
or whatever the case may be the school
profits awful all that and the key it
just gets the scholarship got the browns
coming to town what's your relationship
with Odell Beckham we're friends you
know he's a great guy since he was
pretty young you know he gets a lot of
attention but he's a great guy in his
great football player what is it is it
harder to play against somebody you like
no no oh you know you still still got a
job to do and my job is to keep me from
kissing a football so it doesn't matter
you know after the game we'll still be
friends before the game we're friends
but you know as competitors we both
understand what it comes with what are
you doing when your career is over I
thought that's a great question I
haven't I've been totally decide that
I'm working on that right as we speak
you know I think I got four more years
left I want to play but I think
commenting commentating is option and I
think you know baby
maybe coaching if the right position
presents itself
but honestly I haven't decided I think I
wouldn't talk the game more than I want
to coach it yeah well you got hot takes
and that's what it seems like the
business is nowadays that you got to
have something to say and you got to say
it and they're smart takes to which
which is also rare in our business
I appreciate that to come on your show
and be a guest I appreciate you having
me Richard good luck against the Browns
and the rest of the season we appreciate
your time thank you thank you yeah it's
a Richard Sherman he turns 31 in March
they went to play four more years four
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on be our live or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]